if i know them well and uh yeah devin
navarra
now after these couple of victories i
mean his confidence is gonna be higher
than anyone anyone else in the world
beating magnus carson and then winning
that fantastic end game we saw in the
last round meanwhile wow is this one of
the first times we've seen this
throughout the champions chess tour last
season and this season it's the dutch
defense
and simon is not here to enjoy this
moment i know and not only is it the
dutch defense it's also simon's favorite
variation wow off the dutch yeah the
classical dutch just pushing this pawn
forward we rarely see this
at the top level and uh now richard
rapport is he going to bring his bishop
out wow why isn't simon here shout out
to ginger gm if you're watching because
simon is one of the connoisseurs of this
opening one of the pioneers as well just
showing how attacks can be made simon
has beaten players like gelfand
voitershek in this opening
and uh okay computers hate it for black
we should specify so let's ignore the
evaluation bar for the first 10 15 moves
of this game but uh meanwhile black is
the first one to castle white occupies
most of the center and now white needs
to catch up
with peace development and okay oh
not what simon likes to see it's kind of
transposed away from simon's favorite
classical dutch to what we call the
stone wall if you look at white uh look
at the black pawn structure sorry in the
center of the board all of the pawns are
on light squares it's like a wall just
blocking white pieces out and uh black
is just gonna fight on those light
squares for survival the dark squares
are a bit weak for black that's why this
opening doesn't have such a good
reputation maybe historically but then
again black is rock solid thanks to this
stonewall setup
all right yeah
and it is a very solid setup and i did
ask for everyone to send in their
thoughts suggestions and their selfies i
do have to show you two selfies
one from mariana lopez
who is watching with
her cat and she says cat is very
interested yeah
we like it and oh maybe it's charlie the
chess cat yeah or a little rival you
know he doesn't want to be the only
chess cat and meanwhile white has moved
his rook and someone else watching the
show a big shout out to cj dimoy he used
to be the president of the english chess
federation
and uh he says that he's supposed to be
studying stop distracting me
sorry i'm not really sorry
you can multitask
yeah
and
definitely if you too want to send us
your questions your thoughts and even
your selfies there's still time you can
do that by tweeting us using the hashtag
chesschamps yes
please do yeah meanwhile a couple of
moves but not too much has changed uh
david navarro has just shuffled the
white rook on the queen side across one
square he's aiming to push white's b
pawn forward he's trying to open lines
on this left side of the board but
rapport is trying to stop that from
happening and uh it's just a very cagey
battle right now
uh richard report needs to decide how to
improve his pieces another reason this
opening the stonewall dutch doesn't have
such a great reputation is because
black's light squared bishop tends to
get locked in behind its own pawns so
often the black light square bishop is
about to say has it just moved no it
hasn't the knight moves instead that
bishop is the problem child it needs to
somehow wiggle its way out over to the
kingside and somehow trade itself off
because black does have one bad piece
and often a bad piece makes your whole
position bad uh meanwhile the rapport
just brings his knight out instead i'm
not such a fan of that i must admit but
uh okay at least black for the time
being still rock solid yeah definitely
rock solid but i agree with you this
doesn't
doesn't fit the rules of the stone wall
because uh the normal stable thing that
i see is that
like you mentioned the light square
bishop goes on an odyssey and kind of
does a little zigzagging movement along
the back row and gets all the way to the
right side or alternatively
but this is a lot more risky is actually
to try to get her out via the left side
of the board by doing this
uh rapport is just saying hey i'm gonna
leave the bishop behind and i'm gonna
focus on putting the knight in the
middle of the board and uh well
oh oh
it's uh never too late to admit that you
made a mistake there's one of the
mountain rules in norway that i found
out that's true
i just want to mention you guys look at
the donation bar we have made it to
49
000 in our fundraiser for unicef come on
let's make it to 50 000 by the end of
day two that would be fantastic and you
can donate if we get up the qr code you
can scan that with your phone uh or you
head to chess24.com
donate come on let's make it to 50 000
by the end of today that would be a
fantastic number to help the people of
ukraine yeah
how much is needed it's like we're 49
000 and it's like 900 away
are we
there we go yeah just over 900 away okay
undead sorry
yeah and uh okay meanwhile yeah still no
moves as you mentioned uh richard
rapport lost a bit of time over the last
couple of turns just bringing his knight
forward and then having to retreat it to
its start square
davina navarro though as we're used to
from him may just trying to work out
what to do just scratching his head
there
white ideally wants to start pushing
forward black's pieces are very very
passive but it's not easy to do that
white can't break forward in the center
yet white can't open lines there because
black's
pawns are just blunting any potential
pawn breaks pawn pushes and therefore
okay he just lifts his queen up the
board that's a good move i was going to
say i'm hoping he didn't retreat the
white knight on the kingside back to
where he came from because that would
have actually repeated the position for
the second time and um just to show some
ideas and just to show what has been
happening over the last few turns
because some viewers at home might be
wondering why did black bring the knight
out to the square and then retreat it to
its home because after white's knight
jump attacking this weak pawn another
problem child uh in the stonewall
structure black's knight had to move out
the way if black's knight jumped forward
indirectly now defending this pawn then
suddenly whoops this knight gets trapped
the pawn would step forward this night
now has no safe squares to go to if it
leaps forward again then it does
get caught by this white pawn and that
meant that after the knight did jump
forward the black knight had to jump
back where it came from again utilizing
this bishop to defend the weak pawn and
after the queen steps forward black has
pushed his pawn forward and uh now
finally the black knight is let out of
its cage again but uh white has
definitely gained something here
white has gained a really useful queen
move a nice uh square in the center of
the board guarding this pawn as well
black meanwhile has weakened himself
slightly on this flank and look at this
navarra he's full of confidence right
now because he's just thrown his pawn
forward and after a trade he's trying to
push forward even further to undermine
black's structure we talked about the
stonewall it's basically this structure
this wall of pawns on the light squares
and white wants to erode that wall
but black does have some say in the
matter and he's using his knight now to
target this pawn trying to force white
to make a commitment if white pushes
forward maybe the black knight is going
to creep into the enemy half and uh
actually it's a real thorn in white side
here this night supported on an outpost
by its pawn yeah
but uh you know me
it's like waving a little red flag you
know you want me to push the pawn i'll
do it with pleasure
absolutely and it's so nice that you
guys have different styles in that sense
so we you know we get uh do we get both
styles
but i i yeah
my style definitely does have its
disadvantage maybe i'm a little bit too
optimistic at times but uh here i was
just going to say my big plan is as
david highlighted is to push the other
pawn one square forward and my one
philosophy in life is that
if your opponent puts a piece in your
side of the board you should be really
possessive about your own side you'll be
like haha this is mine either you chase
it away or you try to swap it off if
it's super annoying swap that piece off
yeah so for example in that line as you
mentioned ivanka if white's pawn steps
forward if the black knight does enter
the first four ranks just swap it off
for your own knight just don't let it
sit there too long otherwise it will
cause some damage
and yeah why not throw the sea pawn
forward throw the b pawn forward
i know you advocate pushing pawns and
sometimes i disagree if i can put here a
full heart yeah
fully support that uh that philosophy
throw those pawns forward because what
else for white simply
i have a nickname for this type of pawn
structure okay i call it
and no one else in the world calls it
this by the way
that well i call it the big clamp okay
ah i call it the big clamp because you
know
and it hasn't happened oh boom
it's sad about that actually but uh the
whole idea is just simply you just clamp
down on the space and when you kind of
control black's potential pawn push
that's it i saw you said big clamp first
they clamp
i was imagining the a clamp
a clamp yeah
that character from futurama i don't
know what his name is doctor
i don't know sorry
for something yeah right yeah yeah
shellfish
it's kind of michelle yeah and it's oh
it's delicious yes i had clams the other
day actually
stop it making us hungry
and meanwhile a couple of moves so not
the big clamp clamping down on the
position locking things up uh nevarra
instead brought the white knight to the
center and following the other rule that
we mentioned as soon as peace jumps into
your heart trying to evict it uh black
has done the same so uh white's knight
jumped into black's first four ranks and
black's knight has retreated to try and
trade off and uh try and evict that
white knight in the middle uh white's
knight in the center of the board that
just too strong so uh okay david navarro
has an issue to deal with
what's he gonna do still does he want to
allow a night trade no because black is
the one cramped this time black has
lacking space and any exchanges that
occur will favor richard report so i'm
very surprised david navarro went into
this rather than european ivanka because
um yeah here a set of knights is
definitely uh about to get traded off or
or is it
david navarro now going on the attack
and uh he with his white knight is
attacking a black bishop attacking
black's rook at the top of the board
he's really trying to fight for
territory here but he has sacrificed to
pawn and richard report grabbed that
pawn instantly white's queen now under
fire white's queen has to move yeah
she's just going to shuffle one square
to the side maybe attack some weak pawns
is she going to retreat
either way devon navarro taking big big
risks
yeah i think
that night move wasn't really great like
you suggested and now i just think that
richard's kind of gotten away with it
and i think richard is absolutely fine
although he has to be careful he has to
be careful because if david were to step
back with with the queen along the
diagonal then maybe there might be some
options of just exploding open the
center and just releasing the power of
the light squared bishop yeah so for
example okay he hasn't done this but i
was going to say now there is this
double attack the rook is the more
valuable piece so the rook has to move
and for example after a trade here white
could explode things open push pawns
forward and after a trade here for
example okay white can take with a
bishop with a knight but white does have
the power of the bishop pair these
bishops now facing down on some
diagonals towards the black king but if
we catch up with the game this didn't
happen white slid across with his queen
blocking his own pawns but eyeing up
this weakness in the center and a couple
of moves later the rook moved we saw a
trade night for bishop so white has the
bishop pair but it's all about opening
lines up for that bishop and with this
pawn push he's trying to undermine black
structure he's trying to open up this
diagonal for white's fiance bishop and
uh to me it still looks like white has
great compensation wipes down the pawn
but uh his piece is just superior and
black meanwhile on the defensive bring
his queen forward
indirectly defending this pawn as well
and uh
richard reports
i've seen him on the white side of these
positions plenty of times i'm not so
sure he's going to be happy look at the
dark squares as well black's
been shawn of a dark square bishop and
therefore his dark squares are going to
be weak if this guy enters the action
for example if the white queen was
somehow to get out the way safely i'm
not sure you want to do this yet but the
bishop could join the action with
devastating effect later on
and uh okay david navarro needs to find
a way to open up his bishops he'd love
to open up this diagonal but he'd also
love to find a good home for this piece
meanwhile if you compare pieces this is
definitely the worst piece on the board
this is another reason why the
evaluation bar likes white right now
this bishop blocked in not contributing
to the battle at all
yeah
i i agree there is a lot of danger but i
have to say it does seem to be
a trademark of richard to grab a pawn
and then like survive
and just uh bank on the fact that his
opponent doesn't have so much time to
find the most precise way to nurture
home that advantage wow yeah look at the
clock times yeah i mean seven just under
eight minutes and uh richard he's got
more time than than when he started yeah
richard
i mean he's made some huge decisions
really committal decisions grabbing a
pawn allowing some trades putting his
pieces on weird squares but he's made
those decisions instantly and uh maybe
the clock will be a big factor later in
the game
and uh richard in the last game we saw
him grab uh sorry we saw him give up a
few pawns against magnus carlsen that
didn't work for him so maybe he's being
materialistic here
wow he did it again richard report he
made a move without moving his hands
just levitating those pieces he's using
his mouse to make those pre-moves
he was expecting predicting what navarro
was going to do and he automatically
recaptured the pawn even though his
hands were by his face so really
impressive stuff
and uh okay white queen dropping back
this sets up the idea we actually
mentioned a few minutes ago white
central pawn the e pawn is going to
shoot up the board two squares the
position will end up opening and uh
who's that gonna favor that's the
question i think it's gonna favor the
bishops but uh report does have a move
before that happens before white is able
to throw his pawns forward in the center
and there we go he does fight against
this by offering a trade of knights and
there the explosion starts uh
well white uh activates the forces and
suddenly it's uh such an incredibly
sharp position and like you said you
know it's all about whether
black will survive the onslaught
and it's very very weak on the light
squares and you kind of you point it out
quite a few times but it's so true
like light square bishop so bad so bad
look at black's pawn structure and until
that pawn was captured he had two sets
of isolated doubled pawns
and uh okay still black temporarily a
pawn up but it's all about that black
bishop not really entering the action
and
i think richard really needs to slow
down over the next few moves before it's
too late he's trusted his instincts up
to this point but he's got a really
difficult position and having 15 minutes
on the clock you don't take that to
tomorrow you don't take that to the next
game so you might as well just pause now
it's a really critical moment because if
white's dark squared bishop
enters and joins the fun then the two
bishops together i think for white are
gonna win this game for narrara navarro
yeah
okay what to do maybe black's bishop can
come out
it has to at some point
yeah it definitely has to and well the
players are certainly keeping us
entertained and everyone at home is also
following the action and keeping us
entertained and i have a few selfies to
show you and naval badri says that
they're staying late
nights because of course it's quite late
uh in asia and uh okay well richard
retreating the work
keeping it near to the king and little
oval is saying difficult choices to
either study
or to watch the chest
watch the chest or you can do both a big
fan of multitasking and heidi m jawa
says sundays cannot get any better so
thank you very much for your selfies
definitely yeah i love seeing them
sending you strength and studying oh i
remember
those times yeah and just a bizarre move
there by devon navarro because i think
he was doing really well
and oh there we go the evaluation bar
shifts and it's because of an obvious
move he's allowed black's bishop power
and look at black's bishop suddenly it's
hitting one of the white rooks and there
was a queen trade there temporarily
white as a pawn up but
i think here he's just too materialistic
i think he should have just maintained
the tension got his pieces out kept the
queens on most importantly because
black's king was potentially weak now
after this queen trade i think navarro
has lost a lot of his advantage and with
correct play it feels like rapport is
out of the woods black's bishop can go
and take a rook right now
what is his idea i think he just wants
to play the position a
piece
a pawn up is what i wanted to say so
he's you know bishop takes rook bishop
takes rook you know both sides happy
yeah we have to show what happened there
because it happened super quickly both
players rushing blitzing into that
variation and it was here i thought okay
white's rook as we
are about to see in the game is actually
vulnerable on a light square why not
just shift it across one square uh you
have targets as well on this line later
but instead of keeping the tension uh
navarro sorry it got greedy grabbing a
pawn and after the bishop moved he
grabbed another pawn but after this
queen trade look at this this bishop
which was just a block of wood which
wasn't really join uh doing anything
joining the action suddenly it can take
this pawn or if report wants to be super
clever this rook is under fire why not
move it just shuffle it across and
suddenly this rook is attacked for white
this rook is also attacked for white you
have a problem because if you suddenly
trade a set of rooks black is suddenly
winning after knight takes rook
recapturing and it's a double attack
this night hits this white bishop and
this bishop hits this white rook and i
think we might see a reaction from
navara i think he's missed this really
sneaky rook move by rapport
he is a pawn up white now but he's not
going to keep this pawn for too long
because both of his rooks are under fire
and okay he jumps out with his bishop
attacking this black rook now but what's
gonna happen after bishop takes rook
this is i mean it's so many catches on
every turn still the same problem david
isn't it it's the same problem and this
rook now under fire for white if you
take black's rook whoops suddenly the
white bishop is hanging and i recommend
anyone at home who who uh who is unsure
about all of these complications all of
these captures to go and play this out
on chess 24 but it's really complicated
right now and the players have played
quickly but after the bishop jumped out
we saw a sacrifice from navara bishop
takes rook he has simply recaptured and
now
another sacrifice look at all these
trades everything's getting hoovered off
the board this uh rook is attacked this
knight is also attacked white's bishops
are just too strong together so why not
get rid of one of them black gave up his
extra rook for a bishop and now after
the knight moves let's count it's four
against blacks three but these white
pawns are all isolated or doubled and i
think this game is fizzling out towards
the draw black can simply attack all of
these pawns with his rook maybe even
with his knight and uh yeah the
whiteboard's just too weak one pawn
advantage meaningless here navara has
let his advantage slip in fact i would
even prefer to play black same just just
because the look of the pawn structure i
mean it's just horrendous yeah it's like
a ugly it's like a
weird zigzag that's gonna go wrong
and uh okay black's king is joining the
action why not attack these pawns with
your king maybe the king going on a
march towards the white weaknesses
and
yeah i think navarro would love a draw
right now and he's going for that draw
let's go back to the players he's just
hoovering everything off the board uh
look at this it's three versus two now
but those three white pawns just too
weak
this game is going to end in a few
moments there's just not enough material
left even if black wins one of the pawns
back
there's no way to create a past pawn and
therefore this rook end game is a simple
draw
and uh okay i don't think we'll see a
trade here from navara there we go
trading the rooks would have been risky
for white because white's pawns are
separated isolated black's pawns are
joined and connected
and here we go we're about to see a
result the position repeats itself
that's a perpetual check three time
repetition and it's a draw they end the
day on a high and a smile from david
navarro he had a fantastic day today
winning two games and two draws also a
draw here against world number 10
richard report